is your weather now from logandale to
las vegas many places have seen the rain
and in some areas we are looking
at quite a serious situation tonight ted
florendo has been watching the storms
all evening
and he will join us in a couple moments
but we begin with orco mana
out in logandale where they've actually
had to rescue some people orco
that's right brian we are here in
logandale there's so much flooding out
here that there were some evacuations
some water rescues as you mentioned and
also some power outages now
we're on the northern part of town right
now but you can see
this street down here is pretty badly
flooded and the water
is pretty close to some of the homes
here again we are close to
the muddy river just east of there and
i'd say
this water here is maybe a foot or so
deep but earlier it was much deeper than
that the heavy rain and thunderstorms
earlier causing all of this water to add
up
but some neighborhoods in town seeing as
deep water as deep as four to five feet
now the national weather service
also reported major flows down the muddy
river and according to the clark county
fire department there have been at least
two swift water rescues evacuations and
sandbag operations were also happening
here in londondale
as well as overton which is just
southeast of where we are
and since we've been out here we've also
been getting those emergency alerts
letting us know that the flash flooding
in this area
will continue until about midnight so
again that emergency alert that flash
flood warning until midnight here
always a good reminder to folks out
there that if you are heading outside
you try not to stay outside and do not
drive in these conditions so again
streets like this here in logandale
something that we're seeing all around
town
that emergency alert for flash flooding
in effect until midnight for now
reporting live in logandale orca mana 8
news now
orca live there about an hour north of
las vegas and logandale now that area no
stranger to powerful storms this back in
september 2014 that you're looking at
devastating flood waters
washed away portions of the freeway of
i-15 and left that community under water
it was referred to as a 1 000 year storm
that of course back in 2014 ted i know
you remember it you were here of course
covering it
on eight news now